okay well it's it's 11 40 now so um
people may still wander in but i will
kick this off
um
so yeah good morning everyone uh hello
and welcome to this talk uh thank you
for coming along i'm glad to see you
i'll introduce myself i'm steve i work
at microsoft and i'm on the.net team and
i've been focusing on web development
for for quite a number of years now
particularly been focusing on this thing
called blazer which uh apparently about
half of you in the room are users of
um now partly that's going to be a major
focus of this talk but also another
major focus is going to be some slightly
more wild and exotic ideas about things
we might do with net in the further
future
so
this is going to be a very very content
packed talk so i hope you've got plenty
of energy to take in all of this stuff
uh to give you a little bit of a model
for what we're gonna cover here uh
prepare yourself to go on a journey
through time uh as we start with uh a
little recap and overview of where we
are with things with blazer development
uh as of the the current release uh
we'll then move on to talk about the
next few releases that we've got planned
out uh coming in the future and like i
said we'll end with a slightly more
speculative look at some of the things
we might do in the more distant future
okay so
let's get started with this where things
are at today
section of the talk now some of you may
have seen some of this stuff already and
for the rest of you this is going to be
um hopefully bringing you up to speed so
blazer for those of you who don't know
is a ui framework for net which allows
you to build hopefully the the richest
and most productive kinds of web uis
that you can the most current release of
this is the dot net six release which
came out in november last year and that
is a long term support release which
means that you get three years of
support for this one and we did a lot of
investment in blazer for net six and i'm
going to give you a quick view of some
of the highlights from.net six
we added the hot reload feature which is
the ability to make code changes and
have them reflected live in your
application so you don't have to wait
for recompilation and reloading and
losing your state and things i'll show
you some of that in a minute
we added a very powerful feature that
allows you to use blazer components
inside other javascript applications so
if you've got an angular view or react
application if you want to use blazer
inside that
you can do that and i'll show you an
example of that in a bit we added ahead
of time compilation for blazer
webassembly and this is the ability to
pre-compile the dot-net code to
webassembly by code so that it can run
10 or 20 times faster when it gets to
your end users
we've shrunk the size of the smallest
blazer webassembly applications from
about 1.6 megabytes before to down to
about one megabyte as of net six because
you can strip more stuff out
we've added the ability to consume
dependencies that are written in other
languages such as rust swift go and so
on and i'll show you that in a minute
and there's various other features that
i'm not really going to have time to
talk about in great detail
there's actually tons and tons of stuff
but you can check back on some of the
release notes or any other content you
can find if you want an overview of some
of that but let's have a quick look at
some of the highlights of this stuff in
an application so we need a bit of a
scenario and the sample application that
we're going to use for this
is something called blaze orbital which
is a application for a fictional space
agency so imagine the scenario you work
for a space agency okay this could be
the european space agency or nasa or
spacex or or something else and your
particular job is working in the
manufacturing group that's the people
who design and build the rockets and
space stations or whatever
okay and you've got an application that
you've built in blazer web assembly for
managing the state of all the inventory
in your warehouses and i'll show it to
you and then we'll do a little bit of
work to improve it so i'm just going to
pop this up in a browser okay so here it
comes and the first thing well we're
going to have to log in because you know
there's a there's a secure back end data
store that only lets you access the data
if you're logged in so i'm going to just
log in and this is using the standard
identity login system that comes with
asp.net core and once we're logged in we
can start to see some statistics that
are coming back from the back end about
what's going on in the manufacturing
facilities and things like that but
we're not really going to focus on this
page in this talk we're going to focus
more on this inventory screen and when i
go over there you can see that it's
talking with the back end over a secured
grpc channel and it's synchronizing the
latest state of all the data that the
back end has got and it's actually
putting that into a sqlite database
which is inside the browser i'll show
you more about how that is working in a
bit but the fact that we can get all
this data and have it locally in the
browser means we can do some really
powerful things and we can have a really
nice user experience for example we've
got a lot of data here we've got
hundreds out thousand items but the user
can just instantly scroll to any part of
all of that data
through this virtualized grid they can
start doing things like
filtering so as i type you can see
that's updating on every keystroke and
that's very nice we can do sorting and
then one thing i particularly like is if
we want to do filtering we can even like
move sliders and just see how quickly
that that's able to react notice that
number in the bottom left as i move the
slider it's like 60 frames per second of
of querying there which is a pretty
beautiful user experience and that is
possible because we've got this database
inside the browser and our blazer
webassembly application can talk
directly to it using the entity
framework apis and i'll show you how
that works in a bit
okay but let's do some work to improve
this okay the first feature we're gonna
make use of is hot reload because it's
my favorite feature of dot net six
all right so if we look at the ui as it
stands okay it's all great we can scroll
around and everything's nice but what on
earth are these numbers over here like
this price what is that crazy looking
number is that is that in euros dollars
and how big is that number anyway it's
hard to even read it let's try and
improve that a little bit shall we so
let's go to the code for that particular
component now there's going to be too
much code for you to read all of it so
don't worry about trying to interpret
every line of this the only bit you
really need to notice is that we've got
a grid the source code for that is in
this project and it's on github you can
find it if you want and it's a
virtualized grid which is how it's able
to perform really well
and if we scroll down here you'll see
we've got various columns one of which
is displaying the price and it's
currently displaying the price in cents
which is not a great way of displaying
it so let's start editing that and i
want to be able to see my browser window
at the same time as my code winner and
firstly i want to change this from cents
to dollars so i'm going to divide by 100
and then i'm going to press ctrl s in my
ide and when i do that you'll see in the
background my browser immediately
updates i do not have to recompile i
don't lose my scroll position or my sort
configuration or anything it just
instantly changes or near instantly
that's pretty nice now in case that was
a bit subtle let's make a more obvious
change let's add a dollar into this
title here so i'm going to press save
now and you'll see immediately the
dollar sign pops up there that's good
how else could i improve it well i'll
change the alignment to be right because
it's a number so i save and again that
jumps across there and i'd also like to
have some thousands separators in there
some commas since this is uh going to be
a uk or us style thing so let's put two
string and i'll have numeric with zero
decimal places press save again and then
you'll see that the comma starts popping
interview over there now so that is a
really nice fluid development experience
that allows you to work on your code and
hopefully
like in a multi-monitor setup or
something that's a little easier to view
but you get to work nicely and
productively okay so that is the hot
reload system what else did we add
in.net six well we added something
called native dependencies this is a
feature that's specific to blazer
webassembly and it allows you to pull in
dependencies that have been written in
other languages such as rust go swift as
long as they can compile to web assembly
which all of those can
okay
so that is actually how the sqlite
database has been added into the browser
here and we'll get to that in a minute
but before we do let's consider a
slightly simpler scenario let's consider
for example this alien liquid fuel
engine thing if i go in there
well
that is displaying a stock label and the
idea is that people can print this out
and put it on stuff in warehouses and we
want to have a qr code appearing here
where this big gray box
so how can i render a qr code well i
could use some net library or javascript
library or something like that but let's
just say for the sake of the example
that we are required to use a library
that's been written in rust so some of
the team has created a qr code rendering
library in rust and we want to use it in
our blazer web assembly application can
we do that well as it just so happens i
have in fact actually got a rust library
that renders qr codes right here now i
know you're probably not a rust
developer most of you so you're not
expected to understand every line of
this but what you should hopefully be
able to get is we're using something
that generates qr codes this comes from
a third-party rust package or crate as
they call it
to render the qr code and we're
exporting a function called generate qr
code and we want to be able to call this
from our blazerwebassembly.net code all
right so how can we compile and use this
well let's just move my screen around a
little bit i can very easily just build
this using rust standard build tool
chain cargo
because this project has already been
configured to produce webassembly
binaries and you'll notice when i did
that in my source control window it
shows that i've just generated this file
librusqr.a and that actually contains
webassembly bytecode so let's use that
in our dot net code and the way we can
do it with this native dependencies
feature is
we can add
a native file reference to our project
and tell it that we want to use this lib
rust qr that we've just built
and then inside our laser component we
can call exports from it so i've got
this laser component called qr code here
and that is the thing that's trying to
render a qr code into an html canvas and
the way it does that is it's got this
buffer here and we need to populate it
with the qr code and in fact we can do
so just by calling this generate qr code
so we're importing lib rust qr there and
we're defining a net representation of
what the export is and then we can call
it so let's do that shall we i'm going
to just bring my browser window back
into view here and then i'm going to
uncomment this line and press save and
then hot reload should happen and then
in the browser you'll see we've now got
our qr code coming up so that's actually
calling in from.net to rust
and it's the same approach that we could
use to add sql line and in fact when
i've done an earlier version of this
talk last year i had to show people how
to compile sqlite to webassembly how to
add a native file reference how to add
all of these different dll import and
extern methods and stuff wouldn't it be
nice if someone could do all that work
for you and just put it all in a package
well great news they can and they have
that's one of the ways that we designed
the native file references it can just
go into a package so in fact if we look
inside the project file you'll see that
the way that i'm using sqlite is by
adding these two packages sqlite pcl raw
that contains binaries for sqlite for
windows linux mac ios android and as of
a couple of months ago webassembly so
simply by adding that package
and also the entity framework one we can
just use the normal entity framework
apis and it just works across all
platforms we don't need to think about
anymore so that's pretty nice well done
to the people who created this package
okay so that's native file references
what about this javascript interop
improvements well when you're
writing.net code in blazer whether
that's plays a webassembly or blazer
server sometimes you need to call into
javascript that's what js interop is for
and in the past that was exclusively
done by serializing any parameters and
return values as json because that's a
nice way of transferring things
between.net and javascript but it's not
so good if you want to pass binary data
because you know text is not as
efficiently compact as binary data so
what we did in dot net six is we
improved it so that if you pass any byte
arrays or any streams they'll be
transferred in a very efficient format
and not json serialized and in fact
we're already using that here so you'll
see that after we've called rust to
populate this
byte buffer here we call invoke this
javascript method buffer to canvas and
we're passing to it this thing here
buffer which if you look closely is a
byte array and that now just works which
wouldn't have just worked before but now
it does and it's a very efficient way of
getting data out of net memory into
javascript memory whether you're using
webassembly or blazer server so that's
that feature
okay now last one of the dot net six
features i'm going to show you the
ability to use blazer components whether
it's blazer server or blazer web
assembly inside other javascript
applications for example if you've got
an angular react or something
application now our scenario for this
then is going to be as follows
you work in the manufacturing hub and
you're having a happy life and that's
great but there's another team within
your space agency called the missions
control team that's the team that deals
with people who are actually in space
and keeping track of their missions and
things like that it's a different team
they've made some different technology
choices and they've built their
application in react now i've actually
got their application over here in no
over here okay nvs code and i'm going to
open it in my browser so here it comes
there it is all right so this is mission
control and it keeps track of where
satellites are and you know how long
since we saw any aliens that kind of
thing and it's got all the kind of
functionality that's needed when you're
managing missions it talks to the same
back end so of course we have to log in
but it's you know single sign on so i
don't have to enter my password again
and then it's got this equipment finder
because when you're in the middle of a
mission and something goes wrong you
might need replacement parts very
quickly you want to know where those
replacement parts are where are they in
stock so they would like to add your
wonderful inventory grid that you've
built onto their missions control
application of course you've built it in
blazer web assembly they've got a react
application can you somehow use your
component in their application well
let's have a look at the rust uh the um
react code a little bit let's just
reorganize my windows a little bit
like that
okay all right so here is this react
application and it's a bit hard to see
right now so move all things around
right now if you don't know react this
might look unfamiliar but don't worry
about it it's kind of simple all it's
doing is keeping track of some text
that's been entered in this search box
and then it just says to do put the
inventory ui here so how could we do
that well one way we could do it which
has always worked but it's a bit rubbish
is that we could add an iframe element
to just contain the whole blazer
universe in a separate iframe inside the
page and that would work but it's kind
of rubbish because it wouldn't share any
of the state like the authentication
state would be completely unrelated
between the iframe and the containing
app it wouldn't share any styling and it
would be really hard to get any data
into it or any data back out so that
would be a bit lame wouldn't it be a lot
nicer if we could just use a plain html
element if our laser components were
just like normal html
well that's something that is now
possible so to see how that's possible
i'm going to go to the
startup
program cs for this application and
you'll notice that we're telling the
system that we want to take this
inventory component that we built and
register it as a custom element called
inventory grid
and then since i've already added all
the necessary script tags to this react
application i can just use inventory
grid as an element and when i press save
then react's hot reload system will
happen and we will see in our browser
our blazer webassembly component just
show up and you know it's going to work
it's got all the correct behaviors that
we've already implemented that's pretty
good
but one thing i don't really like about
it is the styling of it you see it uses
this light mode here and
everything else is using a dark mode how
can we change the styling for this
application well since it's just regular
html i can use normal html mechanisms
such as css because
in react for each component you can have
a corresponding css file and for this
one i'll say if you can find an
inventory grid table then i'll apply a
css filter invert one and hit save and
then boom instant dark mode and everyone
can feel good while they're doing their
mission control stuff all right so
that's cool um but what about searching
if i start typing you'll see it doesn't
do anything well that's because i
haven't done anything to wire up the
react state into my.net state now this
inventory grid in my blazer component it
takes a parameter called search name and
i can simply pass that in
as an attribute and i'll pass in the
current search text from react and then
when i hit save you'll see the search
has now taken place and as i type i've
got the um you know
typing and on every keystroke it's
updating so that's pretty nice cool and
you might have noticed that the hot
reload system in react has been doing
quite a bit of work as i've changed
things here but what about the dot net
hot reload system if i change my.net
components what will happen well let's
find out i'm going to go back to this
inventory
component here and i'm going to make a
completely arbitrary change i'm going to
change the title of this template column
for category and i'll change it to cat
name just for the sake of making a
change and i'll press save now and then
if we look over here you'll see net's
hot reload system has kicked in as well
so we've got react hot reload system and
nets hot reload system working together
in the same application allowing you to
make changes anywhere while returning
your state and sharing your data so
hopefully you can be very very happy and
productive
okay
so that is as much of a recap as i'm
going to give you of what we've done in
dot net six i want to now change the
focus a little bit to what's coming up
in the near future and we're going to
start with the very next release which
is planned which is extremely soon
indeed uh this is something that is
scheduled for the current quarter that
we're in now q2 of 2022
and what we'll be doing in this next
release is giving you the option to take
blazer beyond web browsers and into
native desktop and mobile applications
and that is possible thanks to the.net
maui project
now i don't know if you've heard of.net
maui we've been talking about for a
little while uh to give you a quick
overview if you're not familiar with
that dotnet maui is kind of the
successor to xamarin forms we've done a
lot of work to make it the most
first-class elegant and streamlined part
of dot-net core that we can we've given
it a new name and just done a ton of
investment to make this really nice and
it gives you the ability to create
cross-platform native ui with net and
target windows mac ios and android all
from a single codebase and maui itself
is mainly focused on building native ui
not web-based ui but one of the things
you can do with maui if you want to is
put some blazer inside it and the
benefit of that is it means you can now
reuse the same components that you've
built for web deployment and have them
be part of your native ui application as
well as of course making use of any
other native functionality
on the device that you're targeting and
still reach all four of those platforms
okay so let's give an example of this
and we'll go back to our manufacturing
hub and we'll imagine that we want to
make a native application for this
so that it can be installed on our
employees tablets or whatever and we can
maybe make use of other native
functionality
so how can we do that then how can we
reuse our web ui inside a native
application well one way that i think is
particularly convenient is to put all of
your
shared ui into a class library so that's
what i've done here you'll see i've got
a project called blazer orbital
manufacturing hub here and that's got
very little in it this is a web project
a blazer webassembly project and it
doesn't really have anything in it other
than a reference to this class library
manufacturinghub.com
and that's where all my real
functionality is all of my different
components as well as things like
static content and everything else that
i need okay so that's where all the
shared stuff is going and then i've also
got this other project called native app
and i'll set that to be startup and this
is a.net maui project if you haven't
seen one of these before it gives you
the ability to set things up in
different ways for different platforms
depending on what you're targeting
and then you can start defining your
native ui using xamarin uh sorry not
well what was the xamarin but it's now
maui's
xaml uh technology
so i've got this main page dot xaml and
this where it's where i can start
defining my native ui and the thing that
i'm using here is a blazer webview laser
webview is a way of using your existing
blazer components or your new ones
inside a maui application and the
component i'm using in this case is one
that is called app which is actually my
entire application so you can use
individual components or you can just
dump the entire application right in
there and that's what i've done in this
case so let's start that up and see how
it looks and works and i'm going to do
this for windows initially it's going to
use the latest win ui 3 technology so
it's a very nice modern windows
application and here it comes
all right so when that first comes up we
should see that it just looks and
behaves the same as what we had inside
our uh
web
when we deployed it to the web okay so
we've got the same inventory and we've
got all the same functionality as before
but one thing you really need to
understand here is this is not
webassembly anymore there is no
webassembly whatsoever in this project
this is just running on
regularnative.net core and it's the same
blazer components that are
being used through a shared library
reference okay
now you may be looking at this and
thinking oh that's very nice but
you know what i've been able to do that
for years already have you heard of
electron and yes it's true that electron
does in fact allow you to do quite
similar things electron is a way of
using web rendered ui inside and native
frame but maui goes beyond what electron
does in two main ways one is that it
targets a wider range of platforms so
it's mobile as well as desktop but the
more important way is that it allows you
to mix native ui with web ui in whatever
combination you want so in electron
you're pretty much just doing web ui
with some exceptions but with maui you
can use as much native ui as you want so
to give you an example of that let's say
we want to change this navigation system
at the top
and make it not web ui anymore but we'll
have a native navigation system to do
that i'm going to go back into my
mainpage.xml
and i'm going to change this content
page here and replace it with a tabbed
page which contains a content page and
inside this particular tab i'm going to
just display the dashboard only not
everything else
okay so i'm going to control f5 on that
we haven't actually finished
implementing hot reload for maui yet but
we should do with the next vs preview
update so that's why i'm having to
restart my application and oh there it
is all right so now you see we don't
have that blue navigation bar at the top
we've now got this native thing that's
just got dashboard on it and i'd like to
put in all the other pages as well so
let's grab
a bit more stuff from my content page
and now i've got different content pages
for all these different things designs
inventory and so on which all render
different root components
so let's try that again one more time
and hopefully we will now see a full
native navigation
menu there
okay so these are win ui three tabs up
at the top and other than that
everything's going to look and behave
like it should do
okay so that's pretty good
now we're not limited to just deploying
for windows like i said we can target
other platforms as well and let's have a
look at how this looks on android
because it's actually going to look
slightly different bear in mind how
these tabs look here this is designed
for windows
because with maui when you use native ui
it will be styled to match whichever
platform you're on so if i run the same
application on android which i'm already
doing in this emulator here you'll see
it it works you know and all the web ui
is the same and you know behaves like
you expect it to work which is all you
know lovely and everything but the tabs
actually look different because these
are now native android tabs which not
only look different but also have
slightly different behaviors like this
slightly weird scrolly thing that it
does which
whether you like that or not probably
depends whether you're an android user
but other than that it behaves in the
way that you expect
okay
so that's nice um of course we can also
deploy to ios and macos as well i don't
have a mac here to actually show you
that but i have pre-recorded a video of
the same application deployed to both
ipad and iphone and when that comes up
again you'll see that the web part of it
looks the same but the native ui is a
bit different for ios the tabs actually
show up at the bottom that's just the
conventions of that platform so very
good
now before we move on from this i want
to try and make sure that i'm giving you
a realistic expectations around this
because sometimes i'm worried that when
i do a demo that's been all worked out
in advance everything works and it's as
if oh we're in this happy universe where
nothing ever goes wrong that's great but
in the real world it's actually more
complicated than that so i had a bunch
of problems getting this to work on ios
and android and i want to be honest and
tell you about those so when i first
tried to make this work on android i was
getting errors because it was trying to
save the sqlite database into a location
that android doesn't allow so i had to
debug and fix that and when i've
deployed it to ios there's a number of
styling issues which i actually haven't
fixed so you can see them there so can
you see at the top of the screen how the
text weirdly overlaps with the status
bar that's because it's translucent i
need to make that not translucent and
notice that the bar at the bottom that
tells you how many items we're viewing
is just not there well it's behind the
tabs
also on the iphone you'll see that there
should be icons there but i haven't
defined any icons because hey i was
developing for windows which doesn't
need icons so i didn't know um so i want
to make sure you've got realistic
expectations your code can work on all
these platforms we absolutely enabled it
but you will still have to test on all
those platforms you will find
differences and quirks that you need to
account for because the platforms are
meant to look and behave differently so
please have realistic expectations
around that
but with that in mind
just think about what kind of power and
reach you're getting from this so we've
talked about how your blazer components
can now run in windows macos ios on
android as native applications as well
as of course web-based deployment
whether you're using blazer webassembly
or blazer server so that's a pretty
fantastic level of reach and payoff that
you're getting for your investment in a
blazer component but
that's not all
there are also other types of
applications we know that people have
got existing maybe legacy applications
that they want to update and modernize
so as part of the same release we are
also adding support for using your
blazer components as part of windows
forms and wpf applications as well so
let me give you a quick example of that
as well
so as well as the manufacturing group
and the missions control group in your
space agency there is also the
accounting team the accounting team are
a fun bunch and they have got an
application written in traditional wpf
and maybe it's a bit of a legacy
application i don't know um but here it
is and if you know wpf you'll know that
it's implemented with xaml and i'm going
into this xaml page here within the wpf
app and you can see that just in the
same way that we can use blazer webview
in maui we've also set it up so that you
can use it inside wpf and windows forms
let's see that working shall we i'm
going to control f5 on that and then
when the accounting application opens up
you can see it's got all this boring
accounting related stuff and then we go
over to the inventory screen
and we are going to see our blaze blazer
implemented
grid there
now it's going to make me log in because
it's trying to synchronize changes from
the server which there aren't any so
that was pointless but anyway
right i'm logged in and now my
application is going to look and work
the same as before
in fact one slightly interesting thing
to point out if i go in here notice how
we've got this qr code there now if you
think carefully you might be thinking
hang on a minute
how is that working because that's the
rust thing that you compiled to
webassembly and you've just been saying
that this is not webassembly this is all
native code so
what's going on are you lying to me well
actually what's going on here is that
when i compiled that rust library to
webassembly i didn't tell you but i also
compiled it to a native windows binary
and i could have compiled it to a native
mac and android binary and so on as well
and then the way that we're actually
using that
in
here with the dll import well that's the
same way that you import dlls in.net on
any platform so the fact that i've got a
windows binary for this means that it's
just going to work the same way there in
all my native applications or at least
the windows ones as well and i would
need uh android and ios binaries if i
want that to work as well
okay
so there we go we can now run your
blazer components in an incredibly wide
range of places
let's move on shall we let's think about
what's coming after all that so the next
major release of dotnet is going to be
dotnet seven which is scheduled for
november of this year and we're doing a
major release of net core every year so
you should be expecting this by now and
we've got a bunch of ideas partly ones
we've come up with ourselves and partly
ones that the communities ask for about
what to do to improve blazer in dot net
seven i can't actually demonstrate this
to you because we haven't implemented
them yet because we've been so busy with
maui but i can tell you about some of
the stuff we're considering so um
actually i have kind of demonstrated
this already so when i was using the
inventory grid as a custom element in
the react application that was partly
using net six features and partly using
something that we haven't actually
shipped yet um so we're going to
hopefully make that we'll definitely
make that fully official as part of net
7.
we're also looking at adding
multi-threading into blazer web assembly
so historically webassembly has been
limited to single threading because it's
built on javascript engines and
javascript has always been single
threaded but modern browsers do now
support multi-threading in webassembly
so we want to bring that into blazer as
well
we've got lots of plans to improve the
tooling for the razer editor both in
terms of its features as well as its
performance and stability um so yeah
look out for lots of good stuff there um
many people have asked us could we give
them a template that doesn't include a
counter page and a silly weather
forecast screen
and yes uh if i get my way we will
definitely be
providing you with a nice fresh empty
template there we going to improve hot
reload so it can handle more types of
code changes people have asked us
hey can i have multiple blazer
applications running simultaneously and
same the same web page that's actually
not supported with dot net six and
earlier but we'll hopefully sort that
out for you in dot net seven we are
thinking about providing a basic uh a
small but highly performant grid starter
in the box that's something i was using
inside the blaze orbital
sample
that is not intended to replace the more
sophisticated grids that you can find
from open source projects and component
vendors but it does provide a basic
starting point for anyone who just wants
something simple and needs it to make
sure it really performs well
and then there's various other things
improving interactions between
pre-rendering the north making sure that
when you use the crypto apis in net they
correctly map to the underlying
javascript ones to maximize performance
and some improvements to ahead of time
compilation today with aot compilation
it's an all or nothing thing like it's
your whole application or nothing but
there's a bit of a trade-off because
although aot makes your application
faster it also makes it bigger and take
longer to download so it would be nice
if you could just selectively aot
individual parts of it that you really
need the performance improvement in so
that's something we will hopefully add
in dot net seven now if you want more
details you can go to the url that i've
got at the bottom there and hopefully
you will leave us your upvotes or your
comments or your downvotes and maybe
give us some other ideas and we'll
account for that as we get started on
the buildingthe.net 7 features
all right
so
let's move further forwards into
the uncertain fog of the future and
think about what we might do
as we go forwards much further now
everything i'm about to say for the rest
of the talk is not a commitment it's
just a bunch of experiments that we're
doing that we are trying to get your
feedback about and see if this is of
interest to you
and this is going to be not actually
even about blazer this is going to be
about net on web assembly in general and
specifically webassembly on the server
and to understand how that works and why
it's interesting we need to start by
taking a quick step back to make sure
everyone really understands what
webassembly itself actually is
so webassembly has been around for many
years like seven years or something by
now but what actually is it well it's a
by-code format it's a way of
representing instructions that are
independent of any particular cpu
architecture or or operating system and
it is designed for running your code in
a sandbox it was originally designed for
running inside a browser where you will
be running hostile code so the sandbox
needs to be incredibly rigorous and
bulletproof and to make sure it's that
rigorous the only thing that webassembly
bytecode can do by default is perform
operations on its own memory that's it
it just changes numbers in its own
memory space
which is kind of pointless if there's no
way of interacting with the outside
world so the other main thing that it
has is the ability to import and export
functions so the host that is running
your code can import functions into the
webassembly which it can then call and
webassembly can export functions that
the host can call
okay so that's fine
but if we want to use this for
server-side programming the code is
going to have to interact with the
operating system in some way
ideally through some functions that we
import but what would those function
imports be wouldn't it be nice if there
was some sort of standard well that
brings us to wazi the web assembly
server interface specification which has
been around for three or four years by
now and that defines a standard set of
imports that represents operating system
type functionality such as accessing a
file system or working with network
sockets
but it's still sandboxed so just because
there are some file system apis it
doesn't mean you can use them the host
chooses whether or not to let you access
the file system or network or whatever
and
like i said this is not about running in
a browser or any javascript environment
this is focused on server-side
programming
now you might be thinking why what's the
point i can already run code on a server
why would i want to stick it inside an
additional webassembly sandbox
well there's a number of ways that
people think about that and describe
those benefits one way that i think is
useful to think is that wazi can be a
universal application binary interface
so that is a contract between a host
that runs some code and then the code
that you're writing and this host it
could be a cloud-based service or
something that runs at the edge of the
cloud like a content delivery network or
a low-powered iot device it could be a
plug-in system for an application like
an office plug-in or a flight simulator
plug-in or a plug-in for some kind of
music creation studio or something like
that or it could be a programmable
feature of an operating system and then
the code that is running in it is just
whatever code you the application
developer choose to write and there are
benefits to using wazi as the api on
both sides of this equation so on the
host side one of the main benefits is
that the code is fully sandbox which is
obviously very useful if that code turns
out to be malicious but that's a bit of
an unusual case a more common case would
be that the code is trying to behave
well but it just accidentally contains a
security vulnerability well even in that
case the sandbox is going to protect the
host and it allows the host to control
things like what the code can do can it
access the disk can it access the
network but even beyond that it allows
the host to constrain things like how
many cpu instructions is this call
allowed to take before i say it's using
too much cpu resources how much memory
is it allowed to allocate so the host
can very rigorously defend itself
against whatever code it's running and
then as well as that it also simplifies
things in terms of the development
experience so the host doesn't need a
custom build tool chain it can just
accept a single wasm file that's been
built by any existing wasm tool chain
and then on the other side of the
equation for the application developer
it means that you can write your code in
any programming language at all as long
as it compiles to webassembly which is
most of them now and it means that when
you are deploying your application you
don't have to care what operating system
it's got being run on or even what cpu
architecture because the same binary is
going to work everywhere so even if your
development machine has got an arm
processor and the host is x64 or vice
versa you don't have to care about that
the same binary will run everywhere and
because of the nature of webassembly
which has always been built designed for
speed you should be able to get
something approximating native speed not
exactly but close enough that hopefully
it won't matter
okay so let's think about net now in
this environment and what uh how we
would actually use that in fact actually
before that just i just want to add a
note so you might look at this and say
hey that's actually kind of similar to
some of the same benefits that you get
with containerization like docker or
similar and it's true there are some
similarities in fact some people have
been saying that wazi could be the next
big evolution in cloud containerization
now i don't know if that's going to be
true
in fact as a whole across the dot-net
team we don't know if wazi is going to
take over the industry or whether it's
just going to disappear one day but our
purpose with exploring this is to make
sure that wherever the industry does go
net can be at the cutting edge of it
right at the forefront of innovation and
you as net developers can be confident
that your skills and even your existing
code can go wherever the industry goes
so that's why we're exploring this area
now let's think about how exactly we
could run.net in this environment you
might think well we can already run
blazer webassembly on webassembly so we
can just use that right we've already
got a way of running.net and webassembly
we're done but actually that won't work
it's a bit more complex than that and
let me just explain why when we build a
blazer webassembly application to run in
a browser we use this tool chain called
m scriptin which has been around for a
while and it's designed around running
stuff in browsers so the output from
this build is the net runtime compiled
to webassembly as a binary it's all of
your dlls that you've written yourself
your.net dlls and anything that you
depend on as well as a bit of javascript
that knows how to start this stuff up in
a browser and then when that's running
when you make any calls to operating
system type features for example you do
a network request that becomes a call
into the javascript runtime that's what
emscripton is doing for us and this is
great in a browser it's great that we've
split things up into lots of files
because you know the download can be
parallelized it's great that we're using
javascript because that's what there is
but this is not great in a was the
environment because for one thing you
don't want to have loads of files that's
really inconvenient to deploy and
sometimes it's actually impossible some
wisely runners only let you deploy one
file and it's no use to depend on
javascript because there isn't any
javascript that's kind of the whole
point
so we started looking at an experimental
new way of compiling.net to webassembly
using the the wazi sdk a different tool
chain which is built of the llvm
compiler tool chain and the output from
this when you build your application is
just a single file your application.wasm
and that contains everything you need
the relevant parts of the.net runtime
your code your libraries any other
static files you're using and then when
you make your network calls or your
other operating system calls it doesn't
use javascript it uses the system
interface functions provided by yz so
hopefully it can run anywhere now this
is just an experiment as i've been
saying uh we're not committed to
shipping this but we want to get your
feedback about it so let me give you an
example
let's start by creating a new thing with
uh net and running in a wazzy runner i'm
going to start by making the simplest
thing i possibly can which is a basic
console application that just prints
hello world
so i'll run that
now i need to go into the directory
and then i will run that okay now this
is not webassembly yet this is just
normal.net core and that's just going to
print hello world great nothing new here
let's just quickly make it do something
slightly more useful i'll get a bit more
information out of it
so i just want to grab a bit of code and
then i'm going to edit that and i'll
change it so that it now tells us what
the current time is in utc and also what
operating system architecture we are
running on
okay so of course i can run that as a
normal.net core application and it tells
us what the time is and that this laptop
has an x64 processor cool
can we turn that into a wasm module that
can run in a way runner well to do that
we can add this new experimental sdk was
the sdk which is on nougat you can try
it yourself if you want and then when
i've done that the next time i build
something slightly different is going to
start happening so firstly you'll see it
builds the hello wazi.dll same as normal
but we're actually not going to use that
at runtime so you could ignore it or
delete it if you want then it does a
little bit of work to prepare all the
assemblies and our dependencies and puts
them into a single wasm file it's a bit
hard to read so let's just do that again
you'll see it builds much quicker the
second time because it doesn't have to
repeat all those processes so it's nice
and fast and we've now built this hello
wazi.wasm file and we can run it so how
can we run these things well there are
various wasm runners that are designed
for server-side use and i'm going to
start by using one called wasmtime this
is an open source project built by the
bytecode alliance that's a group of
companies that includes microsoft and
google and some others so this is a
pretty good one and i can use that like
the following
so i'm just going to paste in the path
to my wasm file that i've just built and
you'll see that now runs and it works
exactly the same as before except that
now our machine architecture is
webassembly
and this is a totally standard yz
compliant file so it can run anywhere
now what do i mean by that and how can
we be sure that that's actually true
well i'm going to use this tool called
wasm objemp to say hey please give me a
list of all the function imports that
this particular module depends on so we
know what the host needs to provide and
it tells us
this depends on 23 imports and it's a
load of stuff to do with clocks and file
system and stuff like that now you don't
have to read all that all you have to
notice is that every single one of these
is within the wazi snapshot preview 1
namespace which means they are all wazi
standard functions which means that this
module should work in any compliant
wazey runner and to prove that i will
use a different wazey runner called
wasma which is built by a different
third party it's another open source
project and inside there i'm going to
give it a reference to the same module
and you'll see it runs exactly the same
same behavior as you should expect okay
cool so this is a good start we've shown
that basic.net code can run but what
about more sophisticated.net code
generally people aren't that interested
in login hello world to console the more
relevant thing to do with wazi is to
explore the new frontiers of cloud
native architecture and build some
modern network services and if you're a
net developer you probably want to build
that using something like asp.net core
so can we compile something as
sophisticated and big as a whole asp.net
core application into a single wasm file
well let's have a look shall we i'm
going to go over to this other vs
instance over here and inside there i've
got
the most basic asp.net core application
i can possibly create it does almost
nothing all it does is for every http
request it just replies with this hello
i'm running on which os architecture and
it's completely standard except for this
call here used wisely connection
listener and this is an extension method
that says i don't want to use the normal
windows or linux networking apis i want
to use the network apis that are part of
wazi and if you're wondering where that
extension method comes from well it
comes from this package why is the
asp.net core server native which is part
of this experimental bundle of packages
of course i've also referenced the wazi
sdk because i want to compile it to a
webassembly file and then i've also set
up a few other runner arguments to tell
it which port to listen on now this is
set up so that i can just do net run or
control f5 so i'll actually do that now
i'll do control f5 in vs and that will
pop up in a browser and you'll see hello
from asp.net core running on wasm and if
we check you'll see that the native
binary that we're using here is in fact
wasm time the same thing i was using in
the command line but other than that it
looks and behaves exactly like a normal
asp.net core application
because it is a normal asp.net core
application so we should expect that
all right so this is cool but it's still
a bit boring right this is just the web
equivalent of logging hello world to a
console can we use more sophisticated
features
of asp.net core within this kind of
environment well to explore that i've
got another project here which i will
set as startup and you'll see that this
is basically what you get when you
create a file new asp.net core
application except i've also added a few
things into it just to try out a bunch
of extra features so i'm going to start
that up now and hopefully that will also
start under wasm time there it is coming
up and if we look in there we're now
doing a bit more than before we're now
rendering an mvc controller which in
turn is rendering an mvc view with razer
and we've also got an example of razer
pages with static files inside them uh
we've got an example of a minimal api
there it's pretty minimal it just tells
you what the time is if you want to see
the source code for that well that's
here
right there yep indeed very minimal api
we've also got
grpc
this is the classic greeter example for
grpc now i don't know if you've seen
grpc running underway before i haven't
seen that done but it was actually
extremely easy to do in this case
because it's all just standard a-spin it
code uh to actually make a request to
this grpc endpoint i need a client
application so i've got this console
application here called greeter client
and when i run that it'll make a call to
the server and it does indeed say hey
look i'm running on wazi and grpc works
good uh what else have we got well we've
also got
uh signalr and websockets so again i
don't probably haven't seen websockets
on
wazi before but you know absolutely can
work standard signalr code this is the
classic signalr chat example the normal
way to demo this is to have two windows
so let's um send a message hello on wazi
and then when we send the message it
shows up in both browser windows because
they're both connected to the same uh
websocket endpoint okay and all of that
is of course here on our native wasm
time binary
all right cool so what have we learned
well we've learned that we can indeed
compile a asp.net core application to a
single wasm file and run it in a was the
environment and our familiar programming
model all works there are some caveats
to what works and what doesn't but you
know to a reasonable approximation it
all works okay but that's not really the
point of doing all this if you just want
to build the same kinds of asp.net core
applications then you don't really need
to run them in wazi the point of doing
this is to explore new kinds of
application architectures and to run
your code in new places where it would
not have been able to run before and i'm
going to show you a reasonable example
of that in a little bit but before we
get to that i want to show you a
completely unreasonable and ridiculous
example of something that you can do
even though you absolutely should not do
but i just want to show it to you
because it's really amusing and
mind-bending that it's possible
okay so let me just introduce this
scenario just bear with me for a minute
as we go into this so i've got another
asp.net core application here which is
rendering a a boring familiar to-do list
kind of example
so you can you know add stuff to your
to-do list and then delete it later and
so on but the important thing to note
here is this is not blazer this is not
any javascript framework this is pure
server-side rendering so this is just a
traditional old-fashioned thing where
the server renders html and then the
browser does form posts back to the
server in order to change the state
there so where can we deploy and run a
server rendered application like this
can we run it on github pages well
traditionally the answer would be no of
course you can't do that github pages is
a static file server you cannot use a
server rendered application there well
let's see about that shall we so i am
going to grab this url here and go into
my browser
and you can see that this url very much
is on github pages it's a real url you
can go to it on your phone or whatever
if you want and when i go in there it
says starting asp.net core server and
then what happens is our server-rendered
application actually pops up and we can
go in there and we can start you know
adding stuff to the list do stuff okay
cool we can have multiple browser tabs
and see that we've got the same state so
if i go into another tab you'll see
we've got that thing that i've just
added there we could go to other pages
like this
minimal api endpoint here and again see
the same state so what on earth is going
on how are we running this server-ended
application on a static file server well
you may have noticed it gives away the
trick here this is asp.net core actually
running inside the browser and to really
see that we can go into the console and
if you look closely we've got all of the
server log output showing up in the
browser console there
so what on earth how is that working
well
i've just shown you how we've now got a
tool chain for compiling a whole asp.net
core application to a webassembly file a
wazi
uh flavor webassembly file so obviously
we can run that in a wazi environment
but another thing that's famously very
good at running webassembly is browsers
so we can now technically run asp.net
core the server inside a browser if we
want to which is a ridiculous idea and
you absolutely should not do it because
it gives up on all the real benefits of
server side programming it's just a
weird trick but i think it's useful to
see just to illustrate the extreme power
and flexibility that we get from being
able to compile our applications in this
way and run them in new kinds of
environments now just in case you're
feeling a bit confused about how this
was actually working in the browser and
how i was sharing state across tabs well
what's actually going on here
is for this url there's a service worker
registered and that service worker
contains the asp.net core application
compiled to webassembly and then when
any browser tab tries to make a request
to the application the service worker
intercepts it and it says hey we won't
bother the network with this i'll just
push this request through the asp.net
core pipeline which is running in
webassembly and then it gives me back
some html and i'll just give that back
to the tab
and then if there's multiple tabs
they're all interacting with the same
service worker which is how they're
sharing the same state
so again to recap this is not a smart
move this is a terrible way to deploy
application but it just goes to show
that we can do this kind of thing okay
so if this is such a bad idea what is a
good idea how should you actually be
using this and what are the ways of
delivering a useful wisely-powered
application well there's actually quite
a lot of momentum in the industry around
this it's really been picking up this
year
and you'll probably see more of it over
the next one or two years
there are lots of startups and open
source projects that are trying to do
stuff around aussie
for example there's a startup called
suborbital they've got a range of open
source projects built around wazzy and
i'm going to show you an example of one
of those in just a minute so we'll get
to that
there's wasmcloud and that is trying to
do something similar to kubernetes but
instead of having a cluster of docker
containers you instead have a cluster of
wazi powered wasm modules so it's much
more lightweight
there's also envoy which is a
well that is an existing product that's
been around for a while it's a reverse
proxy that's often used inside
kubernetes or other service mesh
architectures and it has a plug-in model
written to allow web assembly so if you
want to you can now run asp.net core
inside envoy
there's also fermion another startup
they've got a bunch of interesting
work going on about new cloud hosts for
wazi you can check their website for
details
lunatic is trying to do something
similar to the erlang beam virtual
machine so lunatec is an open source
project that gives you an actor model
way of deploying your code and the idea
is that instead of having just a single
instance of your was a module you'll
have hundreds thousands tens of
thousands of very lightweight instances
representing different parts of your
running application and this is intended
to give you massive scale and robustness
in production and then finally let's not
forget
our very own microsoft azure which now
supports wazi workloads as an
experimental part of the azure
kubernetes service and you might see
more from azure in the future
okay so the last little bit of demo then
now i just want to show you an example
of this suborbital product so suborbital
has got this very
lightweight wazey runner called sat and
the idea is that that would be used on
low-powered iot devices or within a cdn
and as well as running your webassembly
code it also provides additional
services like key value storage or
graphql querying other things that you
would need for your application so i
just want to quickly show you that we
can use asp.net core under sat and this
is not a visually spectacular demo this
is very simple all i'm going to do is
show you that we can receive requests to
this asp.net core endpoint with a key in
value and we'll store them inside the
key value store that is provided by sat
and then we've also got an end point for
getting the data back out so that's
really all this is just to show you that
all these things can actually work
together so i've started that up and you
can see that this is not wasm time now
this has sat and i should be able to hit
my asp.net core endpoints inside there
if i just grab a curl command
all right so i'm going to send a key
event name and give it a value
ndc porto all right so i do that and
you'll see that it's been it says 200
okay and then i'll do another request
with just the key and you'll see the
value comes back as ndc porter okay so
not visually impressive but it's kind of
worthy to see that all these things
really do work together we can genuinely
compile our asp.net core application to
a single file which then really does run
under a third-party new wazi runner
and makes use of the services provided
so that's all i'm going to show you
around that
uh finally i would really love it if you
get a chance to try any of this stuff
out yourself so if you want to get
access to the source code for the blaze
orbital app you can find it on github at
this location and play with that and if
you want to have a go with running.net
code on wazi then go to this location
here and you will find uh the actual sdk
that i've been using but more
importantly instructions for how to use
it with your own
code and again please remember this is
just an experiment we're not committed
to do anything with this but we really
want dot-net developers to be at the
forefront of exploring what's possible
with wazi and using it with all the
different third-party services that are
appearing and we would love your
feedback about how you get on with that
so that's all we have time for end of
talk i hope you have a fantastic rest of
the conference i hope this has been
useful to you in the session
um yeah so
have a nice rest of day please remember
to evaluate as you go
[Music]
[Applause]
you